evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro community we have an
important special for you tonight time
and again as we cover politics these
days and especially the rise of
socialism and the increasing
authoritarianism and intolerance you see
on the Left I'm reminded of George
Orwell's classic novel 1984 which
introduced the world to big brother is
watching you and many other ideas and
expressions that have entered our
culture in fact our culture in many ways
increasingly resembles the dystopian
world of 1984 and is those similarities
that we will investigate tonight with
some great guests including for the
first time on this show
comedian Adam Carolla but let's set
things up with a question I asked Bret
Easton Ellis author of American Psycho
about just how much today's society
mirrors 1984 take a look that word
totalitarianism as it's dramatic it's no
but it actually reminds me of the other
big critique enos which is the
authoritarianism of the left now and
Euribor as as I was reading it I was
constantly reminded actually of oh well
and 1984 no business that took me to I
just want to show you this clip and
we'll talk about it in a second just
have a look
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's the Apple commercial I
remember is so iconic it was all think
different right we're against Big
Brother think different and so much of
what you described the this new
authoritarianism authoritarianism of the
left it's it's through social media it's
the Apple generously sized hundred
they've ended up yeah I read the irony
of it all but it's true isn't it that is
true but it's just so interesting that I
look to be honest I was sort of on that
side of the aisle for a long time I have
to I have to say and there was something
about this language policing that
beginning to enter into the culture in
the last three or four years four or
five years that bothered me so much
because I'm an artist and I'm a writer
and I am really maybe I'm more offended
than the average person about having to
watch what I say or follow a list of
rules if I want to write something or if
I'm going to create something that is
the irony of it all that it really stems
from that side of the aisle but you know
I look back and it always has I mean
American Psycho the cancellation of my
novel in 1990-1991
was from the left as well I mean it was
from mainstream media at the New York
Times and it was from the
nationalisation women and it was from
those kind of groups George Orwell's
1984 was published almost exactly 70
years ago and warns of the dangers of
government overreach the surveillance
state and totalitarian repression Orwell
was writing in the early days of the
Soviet Union before it's full horrors
became known but he could see where it
was heading and the world he describes
in 1984 is his prediction of where
socialism inevitably ends up it's a
world where the ruling elites make up
just 2% of the population with a small
middle class and the majority of
citizens as the proletariat uneducated
workers the ruling party controls the
population through four ministries the
Ministry of peace which deals with war
and defense the Ministry of Plenty
controls the economy and rations food
the Ministry of love is in control of
law and order and the Ministry of Truth
has a firm grip on their news
entertainment and education
just listen to what all well himself
wrote about the elites quote for if
leisure and security were enjoyed by all
alike the great mass of human beings who
are normally stupefied
my poverty would become literate and
would learn to think for themselves and
when once they had done this they would
sooner or later realize that the
privileged minority had no function and
they would sweep it away in the long run
a hierarchical Society was only possible
on a basis of poverty and ignorance
it is a dark vision of the future but a
vision that seems to be becoming more
and more true each day from government
surveillance of citizens to social media
mobs influencing public thought to the
growing push to rewrite history our
world is starting to resemble George
Orwell's frightening view of the future
and that it's something that should
scare each and every one of us we'll
take a look at some specific examples
throughout this show but first I want to
bring in our guests for the air and get
their force here with me former bernie
sanders national staffer Heslin Figueroa
comedian and host of the Adam Carolla
Show podcast Adam Carolla and red state
editor at large Kira Davis there's so
much to unpack Kira I just sort of laid
out the menu there but I just want to
start with the kind of big theme of the
whole thing which is highly relevant
especially when you're looking at the
the the way the Democratic Party is
moving Adam I shall not start with you
on this there's that that the way which
socialism has so really quickly become
normalized within the democratic debate
do you think that there's a sense in
which it inevitably ends up when you
look at what's happening around the
world it ends up moving in that
direction of the totalitarian
authoritarian state that controls people
well however it wherever it starts
that's where it ends up well you know if
you think about the phrase or the term
progressive movement
it says moving progressively it's never
sort of stop and take inventory of where
we're going or how fast we're going it's
just move forward and I always sort of
think of it like when I was a kid you
could smoke cigarettes in an airplane
you could smoke cigarettes anyway it's
but just take a look at cigarettes is
sort of a metaphor so at some point
somebody said look we can't have you
smoking in the restaurant around the
kids with other people
we're eating why don't we have a smoking
section right and people went okay and
they picked up their plate and their ads
right they went smoking session over
there they went oh okay
they moved through a smoking section ten
minutes later that came to those people
again and I went
we don't want smoking in the restaurant
but if you'd like to go to the bar and
smoke you can go to the bar and smoke
and it went okay I'll have a drink at
the bar and smoke and then went to the
bar then they came to those people they
said we don't want anything in the
restaurant but if you just want to step
out onto the sidewalk and have a
cigarette have a cigarette and they went
well it's cold but okay and they walked
out and then they said you know you're
too close to the front door we need you
to move it down the street to the park
and there went okay and they went to the
park and then somebody said we don't
want smoking at the park and it's a
progressive movement you think really
ins the thought is let's get the
cigarette smoke out of the restaurant no
no that's not the end of the movement
it's a movement that never stops we're
going to keep going after you until you
can't smoke in your own apartment
because the kid above you're gonna get
second don't stop and that's the thing
and that's what I've realized I realize
the NRA caught on to this and they're
sitting in the restaurant and they say
we'd like to outlaw banana clips on
ak-47s and they go nope we're not
getting up and moving because we know if
we end up in the moon eventually we're
gonna be out the sidewalks it's snowing
outside that's really so great everyone
will relate to that and it just captures
it doesn't it because in the end it
starts you can say good intentions show
you on people you know free health care
and no one to be poor whatever but if
the end result is this progression
towards more and more control over
people I want to read this quote it's my
favorite quote it's from the biography
of George Washington written by Chief
Justice John Marshall so a man who knew
George Washington he was writing this
about the founding of America about the
early days of the colonies of America so
true is it that men close their eyes on
encroachments committed by that party to
which they are
in the delusive hope that power in such
hands will always be wielded against
their adversaries and never against
themselves yeah that's how that's where
we are with the free speech it's like oh
it's fine we're just out lying those
dirty bigoted homophobic misogynistic
ins we're doing the right thing that's
fine these laws will never come around
to bite us in the butt and we're at this
place where now where it's like no it
rains the word the the word says arrays
on the wicked as well as the righteous
so you know it does the laws rain down
on all of us to say and I think we're
finally reaching critical mass where
people are like hold on
this isn't this isn't what I meant I
didn't mean me Burgas to get wrapped up
in this I meant that for you guys this
is EC telling that you know I you know I
know that many on the left really object
to the comparisons that you hear where
they wear their socialism is Venezuela
or whatever you know I know what I'm
talking about on this topic because my
family is from Hungary right they grew
up on to communism they they my mother
and father left and went the freedom in
the UK where I grew up
rest of the family back in Hungary of
course it's not literally true that
communism and the way that that work
one-party state and so on is the same as
what you know the Bernie Sanders
platform is of course but the point here
and the point Adam just put so well is
that it just does it always end up
moving in that direction because when
you're trying to do things for everyone
in the end that brings with it the
necessity of government coercion and
control I love that analogy that Adam
did and I want to piggyback on his
analogy by saying when you talk use the
smoking analogy who determines what's
the cancer you know who determines
what's good and what's bad so when you
talk about okay let's move the smokers
out let's go a little bit further well
the reason was hey we're saying it's a
health hazard so when we look at free
speech we are literally having people
determine what is good and what is bad
for people what is the cancer that gets
among us and takes control and you're
absolutely right when I signed up with
Bernie Sanders it was for that reason to
say that you just can't choose two
people or one person as the anointed
person at that time Hillary Clinton and
have no other independent thought well
what that has happened with the Sanders
move
it's now the same people that were
saying listen we want diverse thought we
want different opinions now his
followers are now saying no it's either
his way or the highway we actually don't
want independent thought we actually
don't want to hear anybody else's views
that are on so it just plays back to
analogy that it's never enough it goes
further and further and further and
further no matter what we do no matter
what we say it's never enough and I want
to personally point out that this is
absolutely gonna hurt African Americans
at its worst I've talked about it time
and time again we cannot me being racial
justice director a former for Bernie
Sanders I believe in justice and justice
means that we take into account both
sides of the testimony that we actually
look at things from an objective
standpoint this hang them highs spread
them wide
you know ideology based off of one thing
that someone said like the me2 movement
of course I believe women but we can't
just be in a society to say we believe
women no matter what and we won't take
anybody's accountants with that it's
absolutely going to come back we're
gonna get to that later in this whole
question of language because it's really
at the heart of it but before we take a
break a quick reminder be sure to check
out my latest episode of deep dive on
Fox Nation com where we talked about
health care here's a quick look correct
me if I'm wrong but Medicaid is a form
of public option right it is and it
doesn't work we have 74 million people
in this country don't don't say Medicaid
works California it's called medical 30
Cal and a third of Californians are now
on medical that the problem is that
Doc's that treat patients under medical
are paid 40 percent below what they get
paid for treating private patients the
result is that a lot of Doc's now won't
take medical patients emergency room use
in this country is up